can we talk for a second about the elf
in the room which was this sunday i know
you've talked about it
no go ahead yeah what do you got i mean
you surprised you right
well my take away is this the the logan
paul came in in as
you watch it correct you didn't watch
highlights or something all right yeah
he came in in the best shape like you
could be yeah
first of all second of all you know he
has a work ethic
right so he obviously worked his ass off
to be ready
for whatever rounds yeah and he's also
[ __ ] huge
he's also huge and he he didn't
necessarily you know he connected a
couple times more than most
a lot of most great fighters have done
to floyd he killed he landed
yeah but for the most part he can take a
shot too
yeah he took he took a couple of his
legs gave out there for a second yeah i
was when i watched it
i didn't i didn't see that i'm talking
like if man i would like
if floyd wasn't there he would have
found if he's the ring
i'm here i would like i'm looking up
like this oh yeah you're real close you
shot his legs
yeah his legs went and then he was like
and then floyd like grabbed them it was
like trying to dirt i'm like oh floyd
backs up he might but you know he
recovered
yeah i just impressed with this yeah i
think the biggest takeaway too is
you know floyd especially seeing him in
person floyd look 44 years old that's it
like his timing's not there
no like the timing he was off and then a
mixture of him being 44
timings off power's not there the
quickness in there logan paul's way
bigger so if you know the score granted
the score wasn't judged but if it was
floyd won the fight
but my point when i say logan won i mean
he won for
what his agenda was he didn't get
finished he looked
like a boxer and have you ever seen like
if you go on any gym in the world
guy have you ever seen a guy with two
fights fight it's a it's a
[ __ ] show yeah yeah dude logan only has
two feet
he did a great job he looked like a box
he did damn and i'll tell you he really
did he's a very
good athlete but here's the other thing
i i i said and i maybe
maybe i'll get take heed for this from
what i saw
it looked like it looked like uh um
floyd was trying to knock him out was
actually trying to connect and knock him
out yeah so the
thing the first the first three like so
i was around logan's team like his
parents his whole team
and his like after the first second i
think even third his team would turn
around
go that's one in the bank that's when
the bank and i kept i didn't say this to
them i was talking
my my boy steve farhood who scores the
fights i went man they don't realize
floyd's
giving him these he's letting him he's
hoping he wears out like this isn't
really floyd here
i was like fourth fifth and six he's
gonna turn on the heat sure enough
and you notice floyd wasn't just on his
back foot floyd gave him no
down time yeah like it came out the ref
would separate him and floyd just
keep going he's trying to just melt and
melt and melt them floyd was banking on
him
getting gassed out then finishing him so
then fourth fifth
as soon as the fourth round looks i look
at steve i go here we go this is this is
when the fight
well this is if he's get finished it's
gonna be four or five or six
four five six come floyd lands some huge
shots wobbles his legs logan's not going
anywhere yeah
that's a big by the way once he got
through the six round i went oh man he's
not gonna fit he's gonna be able to
finish him he's too big
and floyd's too old it's also a big deal
to be able to take those shots and keep
your eyes open like he would go bam and
he was right there
most people don't do that you get hit
like that you back up
you get gun shy you keep it you you know
he just kept his eyes open boom and he
was there and
i'm telling you right now how long he's
how long has he been boxing ten minutes
three years
yeah so they're both three years yeah
same time yeah yeah
okay but they're just they i think part
of it also is
from what i understand i think logan was
a very good high school wrestler like a
really good one
yeah but even that i mean okay no but
i'm just saying well you know what i'm
saying okay there's a there's a work
ethic
it's it's not even there's a million
people are good at wrestling
literally they're not good at buying
high school who gives a flying [ __ ]
right the different
to me the craziest thing about all this
is when i went in this locker room i
figured
there did you know i've been tons of
locker rooms people are scared people
are warming up
it's hostile everyone's aggravated
everyone's doing work there's tension in
the room
dude i walked down the locker room you
would thought it was a restoration
hardware there were
i swear to god no b i'm not even trying
to be funny they were playing
zen music oh and i walk in i'm like what
the [ __ ] is this i'm gonna carry on what
the [ __ ] are they doing
when i say that kid doesn't give a [ __ ]
i'm telling you man yeah nothing gets
done yeah and i'll see him on the plane
right i'm like how's he so
chill like he's fighting floyd
mayweather and he's literally goofing
around with me we're talking about
podcast [ __ ] and um i see him on playing
writer it's because he grew up with
cameras in his face since he was 10.
so the pressure of people judging him
and stuff like that
none of that matters to him like the
moment cannot get big enough when he
gets there there's not a big enough
moment for him what are you doing at 10
youtube youtube oh they started that
early yeah come on i didn't know that
i'm really big big youtuber yeah
that's why it's so big one of the yeah
yeah but so it's like for him it's like
the moment like you can't get big enough
like there's not a stage
big enough for him yeah so for him he's
like he's 40 and he's like he's 42
regular he's small
you know it's like he's looks like he
was injured and he said he's like dude i
tell you i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm telling you dude i've already won
i'm like that's a great way to put it
i'm like i've
i've never seen anybody ever in my life
in any sports be this comp
i like that he's hinting even in the
ring even in the ring yeah he was like
he's looking at me going
all right dude floyd what he's smiling
he's talking to him did you hear what he
was saying dude he's like you don't care
what was he saying to him
she's talking [ __ ] yeah you could see
him yeah this is it oh wow this is it oh
he can't talk saying that
he's going this is it i was like dude
damn did you didn't care
after the fight you see the video i
posted yeah well you went to the locker
room
i'm like i thought champagne pie yeah
yeah dude you went eight rounds of
the best [ __ ] box all the time he
goes i know crazy right they go
i need more energy out of here yeah and
i look like what's wrong with her when
they go why we thought this was going to
happen like
okay man this is not annoying how are
you guys not crunk yeah
is it oh it's that top left yeah i went
got beeline straight for the locker room
what the [ __ ] brandon what's the [ __ ]
win look at him i don't know what i
don't know it's not
this is [ __ ] crazy he was crying
though that's what he said
here's what's crazy though so that
that's so the first two he's feeling out
that fourth fifth and sixth that's the
best he has trying to take you out i'm
[ __ ] chill
i'm real you guys should be [ __ ]
stoked
he's just chilling yeah i mean doesn't
care [ __ ] i mean
hey doesn't care it's crazy
i think people are getting confused so
when i say he won the he did he didn't
win the fight
he won the game
he did what are you talking about it's
it's he did
kind of what none of us thought he was
going to be able to do people are so
stupid
yeah they're so stupid yeah it's it's
got one in every facet
yeah it's kind of the american story
people are upset but they're upset like
it shouldn't like
he's a glitch in the system like you
know he can't he has no hair boxing
experience
but he came prepared what do you mean
like you're saying it's a glitch
like a youtuber with whatever six
million followers
shouldn't be able technically to get in
there and survive any round well here's
my here's my
buddy if you watch him with krs one or
whatever that guy's name is
k-k-s paris one's a rapper
so yeah so if you're basing the
performance
going into the fight based off logan's
last fight against ksi
and based off floyd's last fight against
connor you're like man
logan's [ __ ] right but no logan got
way better
yes floyd age you gotta remember he
fought conor in 2017
that's five years ago so going from 39
to 44 is a
lifetime of a difference in the fight
game and it's also you know it's not
floyd firing all cylinders and like
wanting this right it was him to like
outbeat the [ __ ] yeah he's just like
[ __ ] both of them were just like yeah
i think floyd was like oh he i think he
announced he's like i'm not doing any
more of these
no not and i think also there is size
does make a big difference man that's it
it made a difference in this one where
he can eat his shots
like if he's any small you probably
would have put him down but i'm healing
it's a big shot logan wants to actually
become a boxer right no he said that
he's funny
someone's interviewing me goes he goes
so is your goal to become like
cruiserweight champions what
no he goes i don't want to do that [ __ ]
he goes no my goal is to be the biggest
entertainer in the world this is just a
stopping
yeah which is exact that's this is my
point of view
my joke that was i was like if you want
to become if you want to become a
professional boxer make a buck load of
money
you you you want to spend a little bit
of time boxing a lot of time doing
youtube yeah i mean yeah
what we're saying but but he's he again
though like you said he
he is talented he is athletic he is a
very good athlete
i mean i look at that there's no way he
did look like a boxer he did yeah
now jake's a different animal jake's on
a different path you know he's fighting
woodley that's the difference he wants
to fight
he wants the fight fight yeah and him
woodley's a fight that's a good fight
that's going to be interesting good
fight yeah yeah what's your call on that
i don't know i don't know good fight
depends how much woodley wants to be in
there
man